for the first few months i knew of the
movie 21 and over i thought it was
called jeff chang they never call him
jeff once in this movie and guess what
it's actually pretty funny this movie is
the equivalent of the hangover meet
superbad it's nowhere near as good as
any of those films it feels more like a
national lampoon party movie but you
know what i actually thought the party
was a lot of fun i feel like a lot of
people don't get this movie it's a movie
about a guy jeff chang who just turned
21 and his two best friends want to show
him a good time jeff ching but then some
[ __ ] starts to go wrong so how is the
party time well it's one hell of a party
the script is not great the direction is
nothing special but the actors are well
cast jeff chang the three leads are very
funny they have believable chemistry and
they look like they were having a really
good time which made me have a good time
with them this movie certainly has a lot
of points where you're like that was a
lot like the hangover but who really
cares it doesn't really have to do with
how much substance this movie has and
there's a strange message about
adulthood sucking so party when you're
young [ __ ] your career choices just do
what you want but i don't really care
about the film's message all i care
about is this the movie is a comedy is
it fun hell yes and although it didn't
make me laugh out loud that many times i
was always having a good time throughout
these three guys are essentially the
younger version of the wolf pack jeff
chang and i think with a better script
we can get a good sequel from these guys
all in all i gotta say 21 and over got
it right
all right guys you can go ahead and tell
me your points below and if you liked
the video like the video and if you want
to see more reviews go ahead and
subscribe to my channel and if you want
to see an extended review of 21 and over
with my buddy jerry go ahead and check
out our show reasons to see